a lifetime has passed since the horrific
events of Taco Tuesday our lives
suspended into chaos this new life has
toughened and hardened
two copies please one black one with
just a touch of cream in 25 sugars
Wow tough and most of us I wake up in
the morning morning good morning sewer
babies Emmett you've gotta stop
pretending everything is awesome it
isn't yeah I get it and that's why I've
cultivated a totally hard-edged side
that's super tough and
Oh No something new
what is it up to that beat is pretty
fresh
[Music]
it's like it knows our every move weird
right special this guy was a fierce
warrior
okay well technically I did the warrior
stuff so you fought a masterbuilt and
kicked butt and then the hapless male
was the leader he uh well
[Music]
hang on to your fronds planning we're
going to save Lucy and all of the other
people who were captured
[Music]
behold the star system do not give her
the satisfaction of wooing this
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of trailers to break down there's
even bumblebees stuff too that I'll do
later today if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything but the whole thing with this
is that it picks up about five years
after the first lego film you can see
it's turned into a Mad Max wasteland so
obviously there's a big twist with this
new space-based character coming in
because she has like the brand-new
playsets I think it's a female character
too based on the way she refers to Emmet
like you let this male rule over you so
when they talk about the tragedy of Taco
Tuesday that was the end of the first
movie when the real-life little sister
of the little boy that was the
protagonist of the first movie showed up
with her LEGO DUPLO sets and it looked
like they were just gonna take over a
Godzilla style and destroy the city I
gotta tell you something now that I'm
letting you come down here and play
guess who else gets to come down here
and play your sister
no peridot : we are here to destroy you
oh the directors said that that
real-life little sister character is
gonna be a bigger character during the
second movie so I think you know the big
surprises is that because it's like five
years later she's older and playing with
more sophisticated LEGO sets and they
might be using the Mad Max fury road
metaphor of this wasteland to say that
the little boy has aged out of his Lego
toys and isn't playing with them anymore
so usually what you find with movies
like this is that they'll like whatever
the disagreement is it's some
misunderstanding look in the way that
the villain of the first film was Will
Ferrell the little kids dad that only
wanted him to play according to the
instructions and he just wanted to do
whatever he wanted to do with them so
obviously there's all kinds of movie
references in here I'm wondering if
they're going to space if there's gonna
be a lot of Star Wars references but
there's actually a really cool Easter
Egg for the movie itself to the fact
that they are going to outer space if
you're like a longtime lego fan or a
lego collector the lego space line was
one of the next big evolutions of lego
itself in the play sets that they sold
way back in the 70s
so like originally they had like an
old-school regular play set but then
they're like okay what are we gonna do
now what's the cool new toy that wound
up being their lego space sent now the
character from that the spaceman was a
character in the first film he was the
guy in this blue outfit
but she looks like something more recent
so this might be them doing a version of
lego galaxy like you know you go from
like one planet to a whole galaxy of
planets lego galaxy is like one of the
current big space-based lego playset
toys right now that you can buy so don't
forget that product placement like they
want to sell a lot of Lego toys and tell
a really good story they also use
Beastie Boys intergalactic planetary so
there might be a villain of the film
from the Galactic Lego playset but
they're all kinds of clues here that
she's not a bad character and she's
probably human just like them but they
just have the blast shield down they
probably just don't want you to know
that she's won a girl character and two
looks just like them so I think the
whole thing here is like the little
sister in real
just wants to play with these toys like
they're making it seem like she's
abducting them but maybe she really just
needs their help with some big
space-based conflict of course they
brought back Will Arnett's Lego Batman
if you haven't seen the Lego Batman
movie be sure to watch it it's actually
pretty good Zach Galifianakis plays the
Joker
they drop every Batman DC Comics joke
that you could possibly think of so if
you're a longtime Batman fan that has
watched all the movies all the TV shows
going back to Adam West and read the
comics you'll spot all kinds of Easter
eggs it's actually really fun company
hey man are you you having the 57th
annual Justice League anniversary party
without sometimes I don't get Superman's
emails for years let me know in the
comments though what do you think about
this so far and what did you think about
the first lego movie I thought you know
lego movie and Lego Batman were really
good the only one that I haven't watched
is the Ninjago movie because I heard it
was really bad but for the most part the
lego movies have actually been pretty
good but what will happen next is is
I'll post a Transformers bumblebee
trailer video they're doing the 80s Gen
1 versions of the characters that's why
he's a VW beetle so maybe they'll bring
the classic music back and it's got John
Cena
if anybody can sell a Transformers movie
it is John Cena but also really big news
is there's gonna be a new Spider Man
spider verse trailer tomorrow so of
course I'll do a video for that when it
posts - so while you wait for everything
click here to learn about new Spider Man
spider verse and click here to rewatch
that wreckit-ralph trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight